We've spent hours doing a medley.
Yeah.
These days.
My name is david hallett i i
was at university in 1973
and it was the first term holidays
and back then we had three terms
rather than foursome esther's
and the friends in balmain in
the house i was sharing said.
We're all going on the trying to
member tonight which i said where
and it was part of.
The a us which is the australian students
both in the university students had
arranged a train called the good times
express which went from sydney.
Sorry from melbourne. I think their
bus students they were from adelaide
and the train went from
melbourne through sydney
and took about seemingly five weeks to
get from sydney to to lose more than was
stuck on buses. And tracked down to nimbin
and it was about a thousand people who i'd
never heard of nimbin i had never even
actually been out of sydney
much up to that point and
that was my first real connection
and it's very hard to use later to explain
the way to illustrate the impact of
that festival and the crush of
the people and just the openness
and spiritually just how wonderful
it was to all of us boys
and girls who came from
the suburbs and the unis
and then of course i went back
to uni after that as we all did
and i came up at the end of
that year for a couple of weeks holiday
staying over at ucla which is just over the
hill in the tweed valley and but those
couple of weeks seems to have turned nearly.
Two years now.
Well
that largely was because it was based
around the campsites of the people who you
know formed in groups all
over the. The geography here.
The festival was it was really
interesting because it was sort of like
decentralization in there were camping
areas although over the geography here in
basically people from their own.
Many hamlets within that
within all of that and.
It was unseasonably fine and dry
and beautiful all through the
may every day was hot and fine
and all the nights were. Were do you.
We
and clear except for the full moon night which
was actually a bit cloudy so for a change
for the ground was dry
but the town with a great big
focus for all of the things
that were going on throughout the time.
And i think just the fact of
the people sharing in it's own
and everyone's company on
this large scale in a.
In a sort of a disorganised way we're
also used to coming from organised events
and sporting events and
social events and cities
but this was very very different and it
was very much a make your own festival
and for all of us had been to pop
festivals and sunbury even while laces
and things it wasn't it
wasn't a rock star festival.
They had the african south
african pianist dollar brand
but it was very much an
unknown ego situation in
that even he was sitting on a little six
inch high stage down in the field with a
with an old piano on it and
the balls of bengal was there
but they weren't you know.
They weren't actually d.c.
or Ten years after woodstock or anything.
It was very prominent there i think especially
with the religious groups all manner
of seventies sri this and
other that. Who were.
No actually a good deal more organized than
many of us who are came over there were
sort of open open eyes and open
hearts and open minds to things
and they were sort of.
But they within themselves had sort of a
theatrical exposition a musical exposition
the singing and a performance thing that
that i think strongly touched everyone
as these sort of small processions would
come in into town after dark and go
into the hall and set up with candles
and music and
and sing their song of whichever
particular generally eastern leaning
that these these religious
groups had and the theater. And.
The acrobat of course who came in
town and before md every night
but would be very hard to say.
The nimbin festival was this
or that or these events happen
or these people did specific things
because it wasn't like that at all.
It was very much. This idea of a.
Do it yourself festival it was like you
know the cross between between a boy scout
camp and
and being on l s d through
the both of them strangely.
That. I think in nimbin.
And i think everyone because i mean
it has to be admitted that during
that time a lot of psilocybin
mushrooms were taken.
And so the whole impact in you know
not just visually and all related
but in sixth and seventh and eighth
sense as if you want to count
that many was very very strong on
people but i think the fact was
and i've always felt it
and you've got to say
that nimbin even though i didn't
know the truth of it then nimbin.
Is and was the graveyard of one of
the greatest forests of red cedar
that was ever known. I mean it was called
the red sea and even when we came here
and a lot of these things are
gone now but all of the hills
and many of them as they
have gone had these.
The ring the trees
or the remains quite tall you know 50 100
feet high with you know the remains of
what what limbs they had up the top
and of course even being on mushrooms you
had this it did have this graveyard.
Feeling
and you could see a lot of erosion in
the hills around a lot of the slips
and the slides falling.
So even though you've got
the rim of the trees
and the forested hills
around i mean it was obvious
that this place had been had
been cleared out lock stock
and barrel of all this cedar and it was
like it had been repealed with beef
and dairy and bananas
and loggers and things
but there was a very much something
missing from here and i've always felt
that we're sort of here.
After the event so to speak but
then again in the 20 years
that i've been here many of these old ring
bark trees we were so apparent then are
gone now been cleared or knocked out
because they were dam dangerous anyway.
And of course in that time actually
because going back to the time
when there were beef here
and you could actually be fined
for having trees on properties
when beef was the run of the day you
know too many trees you'd be fined
and you wouldn't do well within the
industry because it was clear everything as
many blades of grass for the cows
to eat was what it was all about.
But that's changed a lot of a lot
of the beef has gone by the way now
and there are many more trees have grown
back up in a lot of the people who have
come in the intervening years of
course of planting a lot more.
And so i think that's it's made the place
seem a lot a lot nicer now than it felt
then because there was
this strange sort of rape.
Id impression that i got from back then
much as i love being here and like.
I love to be out in the hills and
i'd been a boy scout and a kid
and all those things and i'd camped
a lot and gone out of the bush.
But i hadn't been to the. Area
before and you know it has
that stripped eroded thing
that sort of was in a real state of
transition then because all the previous
industries and the reason for
their being had sort of folded.
Because. It used.
Well i sort of came for a holiday
back at the end of that.
I came to niman for a holiday the end of
that university year in which
the aquarius festival was on
and i just as the group i was with who
are a group of artists and musicians
and sculptors we just suddenly realize
that we were this household this mini
community with bales and areas and igloos
and teepees
and we just became as artistic it wasn't
a conscious decision really people were
there for various reasons a couple had
their house full others were visitors
and people coming in but we actually
spend most of the year together and
that point
and did a large exhibition in the sydney
gallery in the hogarth gallery through
that year and started doing a lot
of performance and and music
and i was a lifestyle i hadn't gone into
having been a good catholic boy in sydney
and gone through university.
This was just a whole new opening up
for me i started playing the piano
when i was seven years old but most of
that was in a formal academic sense
and i hadn't really got to a freer and
more expressive forms of music to really
that the evening that i came
up here at the end of 1973
and i haven't really looked back
from that point up in musician.
And performer largely since then.
How you treat your reputation.
Here. I've been writing poetry
now for about 18 years.
I think it was in the mid 70s
i went down to adelaide for.
The arts festival
and i just was mixing with an old friend
richard tipping the adelaide based poet
and i just got involved with all
the writers down there and.
I started writing immediately when i left
there and through a lot of that time.
Also i was working inland as quite a few
of the people from nimbin there was a long
period where for about five six years.
The number nights would go off
and work the wheat harvest out
in the north west of the state.
Strangely at
that time because we were not from the area
which is why we originally got work out
there because there were lots of problems
of potentials for corruption with people
you know grading local farmers
highly because you live there
and it was very hard not to do it if they
were mates the old mate your problem.
And also which they found to be a good
benefit of the times a lot of the nimbin
people didn't drink
and once was stuck out on these railway
lines out in a leading middle of nowhere.
Many of the itinerant workers that had in
the past took to the drink pretty rad.
You know readily and radically
and there was a problem.
The whole shipload of wheat was turned
back from china because it hadn't been
properly tested and so the number nights.
You know 50 or 60 of them would go there.
Each year to work but are also
with working to harvest in land
and fruit picking down on the murray
and i just got into this whole
vernacular of writing about travels
and working inland and then working
harvests and then getting back home
and starting to write more and more about
nimbin and the changes and the people
and just the colour of or lack of colour
of things happening here as well and.
In the late seventies and early
eighties through the folk concerts
and the variety concerts and the
classical music concerts and.
Just the cafes a rainbow cafe and
other sorts of events small and large
and festive events and annual shows.
I just started performing more and
more the poetry that i was doing
and also getting in league with two
or three other writers up here.
Who were or weren't writing
about things local and.
It just grew from that
point to the extent now
that we have regular we have shows called
a grand piano in poetry concerts where
we'll have six poets and six pianists
but i also run poetry events
in lismore in byron bay
and have a touring group as well
but a lot of that comes from.
Just my own background i mean i'm.
I did i did history at school i
did anthropology at university.
So i sort of remain this the poet
anthropologist historian recording
and colouring or trying to do
justice for the color of the things
and the people around me here.
Many people came here many artists
and performers have come to
nimbin over the last two decades.
You know for many of you know
sydney brisbane melbourne.
The capital cities but as you see.
Been a great diversity to them which i think
as a time was gone on this is this is
being one of the magical
things about the place here.
I think niman would have been very boring
if you had you know 2000 people all
saying bob dylan and or cat
stevens and not much else
but i think the diversity of things
here is that. We are a rural community.
Whatever else no might be it is that
isolated just by the geography of
that it's you know 20 miles to
the nearest large town and that.
As the musical
and artistic community here people became
thrown together who in other situations
in towns and cities wouldn't
have been put together.
And that made the interesting
crossover of you know.
Indian playing with western folkies and
celtic music playing with rock people
and celtic news. Those playing with the
reggae and just i think the larger events.
And things like the nimbin
all-stars and the nimh
and folk club started rubbing a lot of
the shoulders off the edges between the
various performers such that now.
I mean the differences and the
bad chemistries are always there
and they grow to with the good things
but i think it's got to a situation where
across the board a lot of these museums
and other people can work together
in situations you wouldn't imagine.
And also in the artistic situation where
you can have for example we had a recent
spring arts festival where there was a
lot of arts crafts furniture woodwork
ceramics jewelry and things on display but
that was way of an into
the performance of.
Of ensembles baroque ensembles classical
ensembles jazz pianists poetry readings on
guard dance groups. I mean to me.
I mean
and speaking as the president of the nimbin
school of arts incorporated which manages
the hall. I think these are
the magic events the big ones
that really have the attraction
for the public and the community
but also for the performers as well
and for the artists because they
do these things on a large scale.
I like to do things on this sort of scale
but i think it is just draws people
together on this bigger scale
and it makes them also feel part larger
part of this of this larger artistic
community
and give them more respect i think in
a lot of ways for what they're doing
and what others are doing because there is
a chip on the shoulder about nimbin as a
lot of cliches that the media
readily fall into about and in and.
I think it's very easy to carry
that like a cloak around you as well
rather to see where one's own worth.
I mean it's ludicrous to my mind to
pointed a village like an imminent so
that places got a drug problem when
the whole world got a drug problem or
that places got a problem with itinerants
and unemployed people whereas it just seems
to be a bit of a haven to these people
and where they are all over
the place from the coast in.
Land anyway just that the finger
gets pointed to in a bad way
and i think the media is not helped a lot
of the artists to feel you know how they
step out from that whereas
i go out to the outside.
Well now and i'm a nimbin performance
poet and that's what i do and i find
that there's a fascination i
go to sydney or melbourne
and there's an absolute
fascination about nimbin
and any anthropologist
who story in poet's.
Words about and then i don't know what it
is it's like it's like the daytrippers.
I mean newman's got a bad
reputation in many ways
and yet during any holiday period.
The volvo's in the commodores
and the daytrippers with their world to do
white nylon reebok jacuzzi families come
over here on mass every holiday period.
I don't know what they are their
attraction is i can say why i come here.
I don't know whether they're. They come for
a bit of a dare. I think in a bit of a.
A bit of fun and it's a bit
shocking for some of them but.
It's somewhere between shock
interior also do you.
I mean is like cheaper
than going to calcutta
or you if you're staying environment
you do a day trip to nimbin
and go back home feeling.
Rest assured in your mortgage in the
house back in sydney or melbourne
that you've got. It's a strange thing
some people come here expecting the worst
and a very glad it's here and other
people come here actually open minded and
and think it's this wonderful sort of
smorgasbord pot pourri of things going on
here.
Everyone.
Not all.
Some people within nimbin
speak badly of nimbin
and don't like the clichés
about it and some people.
Very defensive of their town
but i think most people
when someone comes in is only been here
for 20 minutes and a cup of coffee and
and bad mouth a place before they're
in their car happily driving away.
I don't think anyone really likes that.
But i think also we're a bit world weary
just with the necessity of the obvious bad
front page headline which just paint
things in one ways one way because i think
what's really got to be stressed is
that niman is a very complicated place.
It's not a one dimensional place at all.
It's a very complex place
and i really think the best
and worst of people come here and the
best and worst of things happen here
and it's almost the nature of it.
There is a certain there is more than a
certain there's quite a degree of tolerance
of other things but of course within
that this great deal of intolerance.
But i think that's always been very
apparent here as a very diverse.
Lot of people have come here just like
the waves of people have come here the
original hippies the whole influx
of sort of new castle lights
that came in the late 70s early 80s
and the whole what you'd have to call sort
of yuppie established family four wheel
drive people actually came here
with money and property and
and plans even if all those plans
didn't match their expectations
but there's been many stages of of changes
just like right now in one thousand
ninety two going to 93 there's a great
deal of changes and development
and expansion syringe systems
and recycling the garbage
and rainbow power companies
and permaculture developments the expectations
around how all these things will go
i think it is a bit.
I don't i think it's a big question mark
in many people's eyes about what's going
to happen
but then again i mean i look around these
these hills in this bowl shaped valley
where in here
and i see this is going to be quite a city
here in 20 years time whether we like it
or not just by crush of population alone
and by the attraction of the fact
that people keep pouring in here.
Whether the yuppie daytrippers where people
looking to get out of the city looking
for land whether there are the german
backpackers you know it just comes it comes
and it comes all the time. As.
A whole.
You know. Oppression.
In some ways there's a sense
we have to prove ourselves
but of course there's an anarchistic
thing in nimbin than any prove anything.
And the rest of the world is pretty stuffed
anyway so i mean they can't really come
round pointing fingers here when everything
else is such a male's a mess elsewhere.
But niman has been very very
sort of quintessential in.
In the home builders in
in the forest actions
and many other changes in home birthing
lots of things that actually stem from
that that have had influences and some
ways a large influence in other areas.
Apart from here.
But even the new permaculture developments
if they come out anything like the ideal.
These are really important aspects that
that have a larger effect
on australian culture.
Nimbin audiences.
Can be very very tough audiences
especially for the fact
that so many people have performed here.
And so many groups from. You know.
Hippy trippy cosmic religious people
finned horn people slim dusty
all sorts of people have come here. Dance
groups overseas groups theatre groups.
One man shows a lot of people i think
it's a bit of a testing ground for many
performers and theatre
groups and musa's who.
On two going up the eastern
coast or heading for brisbane
or festivals in queensland or whatever
and they think i'm an immigrant.
Well we can always do a show in nimbin
but newman's they had you know
there's an attitude in them
and you know been there
seen that done that and.
I mean you've got to promote things
or really hook into things to attract people
to things because so much does happen
here and the moon is a bit world weary
and of course the recession is
biting as deep here as anywhere else
and there are a lot of there are a lot of
poor people living in this area much as
they'd like to be
and a time many of them can't afford to
get a car going to get to the end of time
and let alone to pay to get in the door.
All right.
This first time i wrote
in the summer of 1977
and it's called always abounds about
nimbin this is called the holy
and the oldie and oily town.
We are but praise
and line said stephen of the famous found
to know right of reply save each day's
words or love
or lack of along this line from muesli
gumboots to house cows for slaughter
intense we reshuffle the deck of choice
and chance rather ruled by meetings
and encounter then would we trust
leaders for no one could be
everyone. Thus stalking simplicity
through complexity count.
Just count. Contrary to contrary for ever.
Diverse our ways we sprout spontaneous
versus structure survival versus creativity
alone versus children and what point
of balance twixt all this. Never.
Still for long enough shades of.
Everything rainbow and though the xt
you rush this town along the way side.
The real estate sign reads fast food fast
country so often blind to the song of the
slow creeks and rivers of
moonwalking the night sky
and bury these invaders to the
land away just like the others
and black man gone and forest gone
and hills slide away
wrinkled fold and fall
and the valley sings of pieces torn away.
We invade a next of course we are invaded
by technology man ploughs the
time we invade ourselves we
invade ourselves
but old settlers eyes trace only the figures
ever walking the one street so many
drifters and babes in arms and
barefoot the colors and the clothes
and the crazies wrapped in
blankets and mud deficiencies
and dreams of guitar blues
or heroine do use the
past of the old shadows
and which way shall we be in
this painted new mythological
town. And so many yet to
come from womb or wheels
or wondering why open or closed.
Which way shall we be
wanting to be fair and fine
and friendly yet not flooded
by the highway flow.
And peace in the valley and
peace at home to blend and be
and feel freedom not to anarchy.
Trying this lost notion of
primitive touch of trying.
Just
and trials of community.
1985 fly day night at a rainbow's been
the one rule in the town is right
through rule the moral is let it slide
from pub to rainbow caf across the village
street the bandaged hand stirring tea
with the serene. And stage the only
safe place and stage type tonight.
The defrocked swami's glory
ims his drunk dance raging
fall out on the floor
and looking up from the world of his to
the crazy eyes he flies on the hundred
other eyes in the room and the
rush of the show into overload
and then the two man dies
unwashed for a week on the sly.
And non-game to even hold his
eyes to ask is name so alone
and so much pain for a word or contact
or company again melting into the corners.
And the night rocks on and wrecks
the benjamin to fast and slow
but holds the feel of
friends and fights tonight.
And the night rocks on to the
midnight hour out the door
and down the hill into the borrowed
veranda bed looms still pumping
and mind counting on the drums.
Shifting sleepless across the nimbin
night. The town rooster crows on the hour.
And farm cocks chorus up the valley till
sunrise sweat come streaming through the
sheets. And the village stays
back with another face.
For every day with mother wit
and mother child father
free drifters drew forth.
And the fallen people planted
like we saw in the park
and the high days out of town
and so easy over the miles back
to the house above the sea into
sanctuary.
And slowly.
A potted history of a day
in the life of nimbin
and it came to pass on the eighth moon
of the seventy second year of the 20th
century of the most published god
that the conservative government
that would not conserve. Fail
and the house of god of
did rule the land of milk
and we in sheep did
and they did give the
name yet to the v8 war
and they did fly home on wings of petrol.
They traveled sons from the
jungles of blood and fear
and herbicides back to the beer
and bosom of their suburbs
but for many the bosom had withered
on the credit card of desire
and the cake of ambition and career
tasted of toxin and carcinogen
and boredom of a sudden did flow
from the river of the aquarian jug
scouts and ambassadors of dunster men alan
and peter stuyvesant who did come upon
the village of nimbin in the valley of
mulligan in the dark age of shattered
trees and slaughtered beef
and banana spray and
in breda feudal lords.
And the scouts did call and
trumpet through the land.
And of this company of rainbow
power of this one alternative way.
That coursed and curl their clans
from the towns and the cities smoke
and those are picked up
on the sacred mushroomed
and slept face first in the done it was
a band of gypsies playing in the rain
and they gave the seed and to each other
and they filed the government papers
and they moved in cars and
vans and sandals and barefoot
and bare breasted upon the
land. Some came running.
Gladly who madly been
changing names and colors
and gods changing the guards.
Into grass castle kings
and herbals flings.
And a free flight of raining
forest dense of market days.
Of flood and fire and for
us. The cascade of sleep.
The breasting of babies over
the hills of the far away tree
and in the time they turned to find the
tweezers to tug at the tick from the tip of
their dick. They had children
and children's children
that grew a coat of many colors about them
that waxed in the old wave of
their waning aquarium waters
that washed and fed the.